so on this show i always like to touch
on some bumps in the road along the way
because i really do think hearing about
someone that someone out there might
admire overcoming one
could help them so for you i was reading
up
about uh last of the ninth and the idea
of
you know booking a big role on an theo
show
and doesn't get picked up for the series
order so
what did you do at that time in order to
i guess not get bummed out by something
like that and just keep your focus on
forging forward
i was gutted i was and and you know i
that was such a remarkable experience
because working with david milch to this
day
is something that i will always treasure
it was so
amazing and sort of formative and
life-changing to work with him
and it really was one of those
uh one of and it was one of those things
like as we were shooting it there was
never
if this gets picked up or there was just
like
it's hbo it's david miller like when we
go to see this is going to happen
and and i hadn't i don't know that i'd
ever
done a pilot you may know better than me
i don't think i'd ever done a pilot
honestly i think that
may have been my first pilot
um so i i
it was you know i i didn't have
any kind of cynicism of uh
well there's a chance that this won't i
was just like oh yes and then this will
happen and this will happen and i
it was such an incredible part i you
know took place in the 70s and i played
this
plainclothes uh narcotics officer based
on her on
two real women sort of combined into one
and
we were i was running around with these
uh going undercover with milch and
it was like an unbelievably great
experience in ray windstone and
it was amazing and i i loved the part
and
knowing where she was gonna go was so i
remember i was on vacation
and i couldn't really afford i was like
i remember like oh i'm gonna
when this show goes to series and so we
had taken this vacation
a different boyfriend at the time and um
we were
there and i remember getting david's
phone call
and he was apologizing and he sounded so
heartbroken and so
shocked and and i
there is no sort of i was uh you know i
i of course you rally and you but it was
an absolute heartbreak and a real shock
and it unfortunately
made me a bit more cynical about um
you know until anything is a sure thing
it's really not
and even now even when i get a job and
it's happening it's really not until i'm
driving to
set on the first day that i drop my
shoulders you know because
uh you know and trust that something
isn't going to happen and the financing
or the thing isn't going to fall apart
and then
uh so it was probably a good lesson in
that way but it was
it was a definitely a it was a hard one
and also because i just
uh the i i never got to really play that
part i just got to play her for a second
and i would have loved to play her
you